next one though lads best strip who had
it
it's gone
it's gotta be me who had the drippiest
drip i mean i i think i already know
all right let's find out what the
nominations are yeah connor's drip
jacket
i mean he bought it for that reason
why is god's clown costume and my banana
clown costume in here that's what i
don't know okay here's the thing here's
the thing i think the clown costume
actually looks good with that when i
wasn't wearing like the hats and the wig
like like like i remember i remember
like i got a lot of comments be like yo
that doesn't actually look bad
it looks like really comfortable pjs
yeah it was like really comfortable pj
was not like other clowns that said that
damn dude it was better than mine
and then uh chris in a hat
i have a feeling that's going to be
strong contender yeah uh cali's wrapper
costume which is which is actual drip by
the way and then connor's titty are
party merch i think cause i'm always
wearing yeah oh yeah always wearing it
yeah even off-stream yeah off trash
taste i'm always wearing
i mean connor where connor i really
really don't want the drip jacket i
don't want it because i am praying that
you all i don't want a service today and
and voted for the drip checks it's
basically just like winning because haha
meme you know
funny it's funny i laugh every time
because people because people don't know
connor has three pieces of clothing the
drip jacket the emmy a shirt and the tt
mode that's all he [ __ ] wears
[Applause]
jacket that i can't wear for most of the
months because it's way too [ __ ] hot
he paid to win the best trip yeah i
better win i better [ __ ] you know what
i'm going to be so happy when chris wins
this yeah i dude i i'm i'm praying i'm
praying come on baby
chris wins
because we're going to get a new
soldier's moment all right
let's find out then
the winner of the best trip according to
the trash taste fans come on come on
come on come on
chris
this is collusion
stop the account i want a recount i want
a recount
i'm calling out the reddit i saw what
they were doing
so good man i knew you didn't have faith
in you guys man you guys are awesome
thank you so much for calling out the
reddit they colluded to do that thank
you so much if this was an honest
election i would have [ __ ] won did i
at least come second
unfortunately you did [ __ ]
wait what were the percentages uh chris
won with 40.2 percent of the vote they
colluded came in second with 30.1
collusion
so you tried to pay to win conor yeah
but
i can't but as but as you can read the
most as the gamer connor you should know
that doesn't work connor we're not ea
here we're trash taste just because
you're a whale doesn't mean you have the
best account all right we're a podcast
of the people connor we can't be bought
out by money
guys you guys are awesome guys you guys
are right oh yeah
thank you so much guys thank you so much
thank you so much oh well at least uh
hopefully i won't lose the next one yeah
all right so
the next award is lazier strip
their mom buys all of their clothes well
chris uh chris won this one last year
right yeah yeah
yeah let's see let's see what are the
nominations for this one let's find out
so we got christmas
we got connor's monkey costume connor
trash taste hoodie i don't know about
that that is drip that's our merch uh
well i think it's because i wore it for
15 weeks in a row it was laziest the
last
listen i was trying to represent the
merch so i wore it 15 weeks in a row all
right and then god me and then connor's
amy i love how half of these are called
yeah it was my shirt lazy that is iconic
i whipped that out on a special occasion
i mean the problem is here right as like
i of course i think out of here i think
chris is going to win yeah because
connor has three nominations for this
one sure because that's spread out
between three out between three right
i'm just gonna win because i saw
everyone online colluding to make sure
chris won
because because here's the thing connor
the the
the award is laziest drip right
uh your emmy's shirt has been nominated
two years in a row yeah i didn't lose
last year and i'm not going to lose
again
how is my monkey costume lazy drip
i mean it's barely clothes
it's a costume how does god's clown
costume in
how does that make any [ __ ] sense
[Laughter]
the viewers the viewers have half a
brain cell i think
all
right let's just find out i guess all
right i think we know who it's going to
be
it's going to be is
to complete the circle
so like that's like a plus minus zero
right yeah yeah yeah someone at all so
he doesn't get on water too yeah i'm
sorry chris yeah oh my bad
shouldn't have worn that hat dude all
right well i guess the next stop i love
that
i want him to wear it again i want him i
actually want a curious george monkey
that actually wears the exact same hat
really i want to give him a skateboard
like this like like you know i want to
give him the skateboard so he can like
recreate the hello
children i would imagine i need to see
that yeah yeah right one chris please
please i'm begging i'm playing how much
do you win by 90 percent yeah yeah uh
chris won that with 50.5 percent of them
so
oh wow
who came second actually
uh connor's trash taste hoodie oh okay
32 points
in a row yeah 15 years 15 years in a row
that's a that's a good quality hey you
can wear 15 weeks in a row without
washing it by the way yeah yeah exactly
that's just that's just the testimonials
so
next up is one that's near and dear to
all our hearts
the next
sorry i can't english
the next nomination is the best rant of
trash
we had a lot of those as well there's a
lot of okay here's the thing i'm not
sure what was nominated i can't remember
um but
what's the difference between a rant and
an argument right because i'm around
this and you go on you're probably on
your own yeah it's like a one-sided like
or like it's one long [ __ ] okay okay
all right let's see what the nominations
are that's rants uh god got troll by
japanese
yeah that was that was a collective rad
and joey you got the brunt of it i got
the sound of it because i said the word
apparently uh we do not support nft
still standby
all right still stand by it uh ranting
about jumping with mauric
what's the clip of this can we see the
clip of why this counts as a wrap yeah
what is junkie oh yeah yeah we should do
it together oh you've done it yeah
you've done it yeah i've got it i've
gotta take a wild guess what you're
doing
you jump up you can't
i would like to try streaming
all right that's a run because no one
would answer my question of what was
jumping
and i asked like two times or something
i think yeah sure and then which we saw
yeah what you saw earlier
um nfts i want an ftc i really want the
nfc's once again but i have a feeling
it's going to be the we can't call anime
mid anymore probably probably i just
have i want nfts to win because i can
continue ranting about nft the one time
i want nfts to win yeah that's fine it's
the one time i'm supporting nft come on
this is the one time
well
do we have from there it's gant learns
the dead sea is a lake are you serious
okay okay okay
i mean i mean
i mean i was very salty at the moment i
feel like at least you got some
representation look at that [ __ ] side
eye you're giving to
that just tells the whole story right
there
he's human boys i mean i i feel like
this is probably the most it's pretty
close to this yeah the most emotional
rant definitely all the audio
percentages this is pretty close all
around uh won that with 28.5 percent of
the vote okay second place was him
getting trolled by a japanese bank with
21.9 percent of the vote oh no sorry
second was uh we can't call anime mid
anymore with 22 percent of them all so
they're about to say
that was a japanese bank uh and nfts
came in fourth with 17.4 percent of the
vote
fair enough damn all all right all right
we definitely remember those rants
differently to the rest of the audience
what's up next joke yeah
i think that's ranting about nfts has
just like gone throughout yeah we've
done it so many times